[Music]
and of course students don't just need
new clothes they need some supplies they
certainly do and this year eight news
now has teamed up with las vegas honda
dealers and smiths to help get them
equipped with the essentials before the
big day that's right brian loftis and
denise valdez are live this afternoon at
findlay honda in henderson with how you
at home can help hey guys
hi there we're back i'm going to
introduce you to brian here in just a
couple of minutes but we have moved
yesterday you guys were at smith's right
today we are at our local honda dealer
in henderson findlay honda there are
actually four honda dealerships where
you can drop off donations and instead
of school bus we're going to fill this
honda truck how about that
already donates all kinds of backpacks
and supplies we're going to be here
until seven o'clock if you live in the
henderson area but we've already found i
think one of our youngest viewers from
channel 8 and brian's got those special
guests right now denise they're about to
go to school it's back to school this is
jamison he's three this is landon he's
five so landon what grade are you going
into
fifth grade fifth you're going into
kindergarten correct and then what about
your little brother jameson what are you
gonna start
i don't know i think it's preschool he
said now what i want to talk about
though jamison is what you did this
summer when you're in idaho you did some
swimming and you also did some what did
you go fishing
what'd you catch
fly fish fly fishing did you catch any
fish when you were there
big brother can you help them out here
yep what kind of fish
rainbow trout rainbow trout these are a
couple of fishermen getting ready to go
back to school your supplies help them
can i get a fist bump before we go
oh oh oh wait a sec you're lifting
weights clearly give me one more oh wait
a second christian kirsten back to you
you better nurse those bruises bry
of course we're partying with smith's
and las vegas honda dealers we'll check
back with them shortly